this is the common sense this is
actually the one hope that i think we
all have here
the father of what you might call
neo-marxism
cultural marxism is a term that's used a
very important figure in western marxism
is antonio gramsci
i write about him at great length in my
book
gramsci is the head of the italian
former head of the italian communist
party
he was imprisoned by mussolini uh one of
the worst things mussolini ever did was
imprison this guy
because it gave him a chance to write if
he was going to imprison him he should
have taken away his pen and paper
he wrote the prison notebooks he wrote
he wrote about this
one issue that marxists have which is
they don't have a grasp on the common
sense
the conservatives have the common sense
they have cultural hegemony and they
just
a lot of people when you hear these
cockamamie left-wing theories you just
say that doesn't sound right to me this
is why the left
has to transform our way of thinking has
to get into the schools very early
has to force on us a new normal so that
they can transform the common sense and
we don't question their
crazy ideas i think conservatives still
have the common sense i think in many
ways this is why trump an
anti-ideological candidate a common
sense candidate
did so well in 2016. there was a woman
who summed this up to me
she pulled up she's just gone viral in a
video on social media
she pulls up to a fast food counter
they're gonna hand her her food
some fast food places tell you to wear
masks i obviously never do that but i
guess sometimes they're sticklers
and the person refuses to hand the woman
her food
he'll hand her a mask but not her food
she's very confused
no i don't i can give you one uh you can
give me one
i can give you one so you can hand me a
mask
i can hand you one yeah but you can't
hand me the drink without a mask
you've got to wear a mask how does that
make any sense
that's what that's what i i just need
you to wear mask when you do your mind
well if you can hand me a mask why can't
you just hand me the drink
i can hand you to math
uh listen sir i have two brain cells to
rub together
and an uh even a modicum of independent
thought so
i'm just pointing out to you that what
you're saying doesn't make any sense
uh uh uh wear the mask beep boop
beep beep boop wear the mask wear the
mask
this is the battle right now when we're
talking about the insurrections the
coups
yeah there is there is a cultural coup
that's going on in our country right now
and we're trying to stave that off
and the two battle lines are exactly
what you've heard there
the people who go along to get along
the fast food guy and the woman
who i don't know her politics but i know
that she has at least a little bit of
common sense left
if we cannot hold the common sense if we
cannot stave off
and shatter the new normal then that
that will be the final blow
if we can hold on to the common sense
we have a chance if you enjoyed that
video be sure to hit the subscribe
button so everyone waiting through the
wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there